one I'm an idiot Wanda is the one after
America's power and I've led her right
to a strange you fool we must gather the
sorcerers kamitage must become a
fortress right we must protect America
okay I'm just gonna stop you right there
you see what you did right Stephen you
portal around that's kind of the big
thing with you Sorcerers portals from
point A to point B and all that so why
are you so worried about leading Scarlet
Witch here when you can just you know
Boop right on through
you're a fool strange you're hubris
blind you oh don't even get me started
on you miss I can't Traverse the
Multiverse but apparently I can send
flaming Rune demons to do my bidding
across the Multiverse and also I never
thought that in an infinite number of
universes there might be one where I
died but my kids are still alive so I
can take my own place without having to
kill anyone have none of you people ever
watched an episode of Rick and Morty no
no not really my thing to be fair you
have to have a very high IQ to
understand Rick and Morty the humor is
extremely subtle you know what it's good
I mean pizza balls
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
where today we're talking about Sam
raimi's demo reel I mean uh Doctor
Strange 2 Multiverse Madness on that
note by the way if you walked out of
theaters and your Cinema Snob friend was
raving about how Sam Rainey the whole
thing was here's your 30 second primer
of what that meant anytime the camera
zoomed in and twisted towards the door
or something straight out of Evil Dead
same with all the gruesome body horror
practical effect zombies and jump scares
flying eyeball Evil Dead 2 frenetic
close-ups with rapid Cuts Evil Dead and
dark man scary hands popping out of the
walls and ceiling Drag Me to Hell giant
octopus fights along the sides of New
York buildings literally just Spider-Man
2. even that infuriating shot of the
pizza guy punching himself and then
breaking the fourth wall at the end that
is Bruce Campbell one of his go-to
actors and pretty much every film that
he does directly referencing a fight
sequence that he had against his own
hand in Evil Dead 2. I mean there's
referencing your own work and then
there's turning in the same assignment
twice anyway well I wound up being wrong
in my prediction that evil strange here
was missing a hand as a reference to
again Evil Dead I at least least was
right that at some point there'd be hand
Shenanigans as a direct reference back
to Sam raimi's past work so half points
and hey even though I was wrong about
that boy howdy were we right about
practically everything else in this
thing sure we didn't predict the movie
pulling a trigger on chekhov's dead
strange for the grand finale but
everything else not too shabby we called
the appearance of the Illuminati before
Patrick Stewart's voice was in the
trailer we knew that this would be a
doctor strange Redemption story directly
calling back to Spider-Man no way home
in the grand calculus of the Multiverse
their sacrifice means infinitely more
than their lives heck one of our writers
knew that Wanda was going to be the
villain back in 2019 before end game
released and before he started working
with us what if what they're not saying
yet is that Wanda isn't just the co-star
in Doctor Strange 2 she's the villain
Multiverse of Madness is kind of an
awkward title but it's also an acronym
[Music]
true story that theory of his is
actually the reason that he's on the
team now glad to have you with us Bob
but okay I didn't just make a whole
episode to take a few Victory laps when
it comes to Theory crafting it's not
about being right or wrong it's about
what comes next enough focusing on the
past it's time to look forward to break
down all the big reveals and see what we
predict it means for the next several
steps in the MCU timeline let's start
small the detail that I'm sure everyone
noticed was Dr Strange's magic cloak
ripping and then getting repaired with a
distinctly non-matching blue patch feels
like a super random thing to include and
then not really talk about right well
notice who did the repair a variant of
Doctor Strange's would-be girlfriend
Christine Palmer in The Illuminati's
Universe of 838 notably she makes it a
point to say that she works not just
with the Illuminati but for the Baxter
Foundation Baxter as in the Baxter
building which is most famously the
Fantastic for his headquarters now this
might wind up to be nothing but in the
comics Reed Richards aka Mr Fantastic is
a renowned inventor and one of his big
breakthrough Technologies is known as
unstable molecules a special super
adaptive synthetic blue fabric that can
adapt to almost any environment
including extreme heat cold and pressure
basically in the comics they use this to
explain how the Fantastic Forest
costumes are able to cope with the
powers of the four heroes Super stretchy
guy turned to fire guy turn invisible
woman and rock guy so if I were a
betting man I'd expect that Stephen
Strange by taking his cloak with a patch
of unstable molecule fabric back to the
MCU will prompt researchers of universe
616 to analyze the fabric and discover
the material for themselves thus they'll
have introduced a brand new particle to
the world causing science in the
universe 616 to take a massive Leap
Forward I'd expect this to happen in the
next movie where talk of particles and
science tend to take Center Stage AKA
Ant-Man quantumania the alternative is
that this is what prompts the creation
of universe 616's own Fantastic Four
whenever that movie is able to find and
keep a director of course it could also
be a patch from Dr Strange 8 3 8 cloak
which we see Reed holding in the
flashback and appears to be blue as well
either way kind of weird for her not to
bring it up since our Ranger's cloak is
kind of a living thing and she was
specifically concerned about cross
Universal contamination just minutes
prior bottom line they wanted you to
remember that that piece of the Cape is
from somewhere else but blue fabric
wasn't the only exciting thing to come
out of the Baxter building obviously the
whole reason we were visiting that
Universe was to meet the Illuminati a
group made up of the biggest most
powerful superhero team leaders from a
narrative standpoint watching them get
absolutely curb stomped emphasized how
dangerous the Scarlet Witch is or maybe
more accurately how deadly Falling Rocks
are cause seriously Falling Rocks killed
Captain Marvel a superhero infused with
the power of an infinity stone gotta
press X to doubt that one Sam and then
later it's how Wanda this all-powerful
multiversal being ends her own life too
forget Thanos and Kang apparently the
next big threat to the MCU is a little
thing called Granite from a business
standpoint though this little side trip
into Cameo town just gave Disney plenty
a trailer fodder role also delivering
them a billion dollar test audience that
way they can see how people might react
to Jim from the office starring is Reed
Richards or a live-action Captain Carter
post what if of the cast of characters
in the lineup though one that I don't
think anyone saw coming was an Inhumans
reference the only Marvel TV project
with fewer actual fans than Iron Fist
and this wasn't just a reference either
this was a full-on return Black Bolt you
know the guy with the tuning fork on his
head that gets a matrix pulled on him
he's being played by Anson Mount the
original actor from the TV show
brother
this reference actually spells some
massively important things for the
future of one character who's getting a
show real soon Ms Marvel in case you
forgot and if you did I don't blame you
because in humans worked really hard to
be the most forgettable thing to ever
feature a giant teleporting dog and
choreographed air fights
[Music]
in humans wasn't just Marvel Studios
first and arguably only undeniable
failure but at one point it was set up
to be a game changer for the entire
brand originally introduced in the pages
of Fantastic Four in the 60s the
Inhumans are one of Marvel's oldest and
weirdest big idea franchises to put it
simply their race of superhuman beings
with strange powers that sometimes look
like Monsters and who've hidden
underground from Humanity for centuries
sound familiar it should they're
basically the 1.0 version for the whole
superhero as metaphor for class racism
and social issue ideas that Marvel would
later refine into more well-known
projects like the eternals and most
importantly X-Men so when it's the early
2010s and someone other than Disney owns
the movie license for X-Men the house of
mouse was all like hey can we make these
guys our version of that so Marvel
publishing gave the franchise a huge
push in the comics storyline suddenly
had mutants going practically extinct
while the population of humans
discovering their hidden inhuman Powers
exploded ah the cynical business
practices that dictate the creative
culture that we consume corporate
Synergy for for the win meanwhile over
in the Cinematic Universe the TV series
Agents of Shield revealed one of its
main characters as an inhuman herself
this kicked off multiple series length
storylines filling in some Inhumans
backstory of being the result of
experiments by the cree that's the blue
guys from Captain Marvel and setting up
the X-Men style protecting those who
fear them storyline all in anticipation
for the big rollout of an Inhumans MCU
feature movie about Black Bolt and the
royal family which obviously happened
and went on to Smashbox office records
and no one remembers the X-Men anymore
now clearly the strategy didn't work
then humans just didn't catch on and
their movie Project was downgraded to a
TV series that very much has the look of
a contractually obligated production
flyer all flies are awesome I can't
imagine why people wouldn't have
responded to this he couldn't have had
anything to do with the hairy sexy time
that happens within the first three
minutes of episode one or the fact that
the main character can't talk without
killing anyone are you going to Speedy
are you going to use your voice kill
your only brother
you murdered
or heck maybe people
take you to Blackboard and the others
block job wake up love job anyway Disney
decided to go pay to win and just bought
Fox and the X-Men if you can't beat him
pay 71.3 billion dollars to join him
really the only truly significant
remnant of that whole weird moment is
that it introduced the world to Kamala
Khan aka Miss Marvel probably the most
popular and widely celebrated new Young
character Marvel's debuted in the comics
over the last 20 years and wouldn't you
know it she's an inhuman in the comics
Black Bolt uses what's called a terrigen
crystal to produce a magical Mist
activating the genetic mutation that
enables latent Inhumans to gain their
abilities so it's been a huge open
question for fans whether the Miss
Marvel TV series which is coming out on
Disney plus less than a month from now
is gonna use a different origin story I
mean it would make sense why tie your
fresh new popular teen hero to a flop TV
show based on obscure Comics even
Boomers didn't care about but now
suddenly here's Black Bolt showing up in
Multiverse Madness played by the same
actor getting shouted out as the inhuman
King does that mean that we sort of have
to care about these characters again and
that they're going to be a part of some
big reveal in Miss Marvel I suspect
Kinda Yeah but let me explain according
to the trailers it looks like Ms
Marvel's Powers have gotten changed
around for this new series usually she's
an inhuman who can stretch like Mr
Fantastic instead it looks more like
she's harnessing the power of
energy-based crystals if I were to guess
it's probably because stretchy Powers
never never look good in live action
[Music]
especially when you're talking about
small TV budgets however what's also
interesting is that these Crystal Powers
get activated by a bracelet that's a
family heirloom so here's the theory
that ties it all back together the fact
that the powers are crystal based feels
important remember what I told you about
her comics origin Black Bolt uses
something called a terrigen crystal to
create a Mist that activates latent
inhuman Powers the same thing happens in
Agents of Shield Crystal equals inhuman
Powers so my prediction is that the
crystal band she's wearing is exactly
that a terrigen crystal that probably
doesn't get mentioned by name until the
last episode of the series the whole
time she thinks that her powers are
coming from the bracelet but the
bracelet just unlocks what's inside of
her all along who knows maybe the
bracelet even breaks and creates the
mist and then does all that anyway then
we learned the bracelets origin An
Origin from space do you know what you
are
no an inhuman you see the twist of the
Inhumans always ends up being that their
powers come from Alien experiments on
humans Cree experiments on humans and
who has a close connection to the Creed
Captain Marvel we also know that Ms
Marvel is gonna jump straight from our
Disney plus series to join Captain
Marvel in the Marvel's movie which is
likely very outer space themed the
bracelet allows the origin of kamala's
powers to stay self-contained for her
initial series then acts as the jumping
off point to create a reasonable through
line for the more Spacey stuff in the
next movie while also opening the door
to the other Inhumans to pop in for a
hey we're around two guest appearance
should Marvel want to try that one again
or you know maybe it's just an excuse to
bring back the inhuman that everyone
actually likes
[Music]
from there she'll be waiting in the
wings until it's time to join America
Chavez as key Ultra powerful members of
The Young Avengers speaking of Ms Chavez
can I just ask I wasn't the only one who
giggled every time someone in the movie
dropped a line like we need to protect
America's power right also her origin is
from a different dimension but her name
is America and she wears a jacket with
the American flag on it just saying the
utopian parallel she comes from
apparently doesn't know subtlety which
brings us finally to our hero Dr Strange
himself this movie doesn't really give
him that much of a character Arc so much
as it's a reminder that he is a
character as opposed to the plot device
that he's been for practically every
movie since his cameo in Thor Ragnarok
he's the guy having to make the hard
decisions putting the safety of the
universe first and himself last however
based on the mid-credits scene that
looks like it's Gonna Change in the
mid-credit scene he encounters a brand
new character wearing a purple fairy
tale outfit named Cleo she's a sorceress
from the dark dimension who's also the
niece of dormammu
[Music]
I've come to Bargains yeah floating neon
spacehead from the first movie don't you
notice the family resemblance here
anyway clia's been a fixture of the
Doctor Strange comic since the 1960s as
an ally as an enemy more recently she's
become a sorcerer Supreme in her own
right what's she doing here well I
suspect it's for the other role that she
plays in the comics Steven's love
interest the focus of this movie was
re-establishing that Steven tends to put
work in front of people he's constantly
undervaluing individual human lives we
saw this in no way home and the message
is once again repeated here the only
person he still held ties to was
Christine but this movie makes him
realize that no matter the universe
there's never really a chance between
the two of them so thematically by the
end of the movie he recognizes that
people have value and he starts to
contend with the loneliness that he's
left with now that Christine is
officially out of his life for him then
to complete his narrative Arc he needs
to find someone that he's willing to
open up to someone that completes him
and based on his personality the only
people able to do that are just as smart
and capable as him that person will be
clear likely in Doctor Strange 3
whenever that wine ends up happening is
at that point that it'll finally be able
to move on and hand off his
responsibilities to someone else more
immediately though is Clea as a plot
device there's this word that everyone
keeps using throughout this movie
incursion which comes straight from the
Marvel Comics universe and appears to
have roughly the same definition in the
MCU as it does in this movie collisions
between universes that cause destruction
to one or both on the comic side
Multiverse incursions are typically the
staging grounds for the Marvel crossover
event Secret Wars which well not
announced just about everyone including
us has been predicting is the end game
of the current cycle of Marvel movies I
mean Miss minutes tease it up within the
first episode of Loki there was a vast
multiversal War when it's gonna happen
well before any other Marvel movie was
even glancing at the idea of a
Multiverse Spider-Man into the
spider-verse jumped into the concept
with both feet that Academy
award-winning animated hit movie is
getting a sequel featuring even more
alternate Spider-Man which some are
expecting will include Tom Holland's MCU
Spidey to connect the two franchises
that sequel recently got double sized
and split into two parts the first
retaining its original title across the
spider-verse but the second now called
beyond the spider verse why does that
matter well in Multiverse Madness the
only incursions we hear about are caused
by variants of doctor strange but in the
comics they had a different instigator
the beyonders a race of omnipotent alien
beings who aim to collapse the
Multiverse by causing incursions
connecting it all back to Secret Wars
and if you think going off of one word
in a title is a stretch remember we
predicted Wanda was a grieving rampaging
mother back in 2019 all because
Multiverse Madness spelled mom but hey
you know what Universe I want to be a
part of the one where I can eat all the
pizza balls I want without gaining
weight sadly that reality is trapped
over there with the whole walk-on red
thing luckily over here in this universe
I have our sponsor for today's episode
new to help me eat the right amount of
pizza balls while still working towards
my health goals Noom is a smarter way of
getting healthy it uses proven
psychological and cognitive behavioral
therapy practices to help enact change
in your life I've talked in the past
about how noom's program has helped me
personally lose three pounds now five
actually since the last time that we
talked about it despite what thick Pat
over here would have you believe as well
as keep better track of my caffeine
intake but the thing is Noom approaches
these sorts of goals from a different
perspective it's about mindfulness first
not about getting the right numbers to
appear on a scale setting personal
health goals can be scary because
there's always some element of Shame if
you fall off the wagon or if you have a
bad day getting onto a scale can be
intimidating because you have to
confront your decisions but with Noom
that's never the primary focus for
instance the thing I'm working on now
with the help of Zoom is sleep I don't
get enough and my sleep habits are
terrible and Noom isn't pushing me into
getting a certain number of hours per
night rather it's helping me create
routines and habits that lead to better
longer and deeper sleep noom's approach
is all based on how the mind works and
why humans make the decisions that we do
and that approach is what ultimately
leads to Lasting change at least it
seems to have worked for me so if you
have something in your life that you'd
like to get healthier about take your
free 30 second quiz today at noon.com
film Theory or click the link down in
the description below one other thing
that I like about Noom is that they just
recognize this sort of stuff isn't one
size fits all yes it works for me in my
personal goals but maybe not for you so
take the free quiz it's only 30 seconds
see if new might be a fit for what you
want to accomplish in your life and as
always remember it's all just a theory a
film Theory and cuts
[Music]
thank you
foreign